There is a stunning new poll out of Texas,
which is also sort of not stunning if you've
been paying attention for the last 10 years.
And what the poll tells us is that Texas is
no longer a safe Trump state in 2020.
This is extraordinary and the implications
are wide reaching.
There's a new Univision poll which shows that
40% of registered Texas voters now say they
will vote for the Democrat that ultimately
wins the primary instead of Donald Trump.
Only 33% say that they will vote for Donald
Trump in Texas.
Once you include undecideds who are leaning
one way or the other, the advantage definitely
shrinks.
It becomes Democrat 47 Trump 42.
Now that is only 89% total.
That's still leaves 11% gray area.
But it doesn't matter because these numbers
are already even accounting for that 11% that
is fully undecided.
This is already a massive change from years
past.
This is something we've been talking about
for a very long time.
Texas could become a swing state, a purple
state, and Donald Trump might be accelerating
that to happen even sooner.
And a big part of that, as we've been following
for years, will be the effect of Hispanic
voters who plan to vote for the Democrat,
whoever it is, over Donald Trump by a 69 to
19 margin in Texas, that is a 50 point margin
to Donald Trump's disadvantage among Hispanic
voters in Texas.
Now, let's be crystal clear.
This does not mean I expect Donald Trump to
lose Texas in 2020 Republicans, uh, when Texas
often they've been winning it for a very long
time, but if it's even remotely this close,
it signals really bad things for Donald Trump.
Nationally.
In 2016, Donald Trump won Texas over Hillary
by nine points, okay?
52 to 43 in 2012 even though Barack Obama
won hugely at the national level being reelected,
of course Barack Obama Lost Texas to Mitt
Romney 57 to 41 a 16 point deficit.
What that tells us is that if it's even close
in Texas, if Trump wins Texas, but only by
two three four five it is really bad in terms
of what it signals for Donald Trump nationally,
and this is actually Texas is sandwiched in
a bigger story which is developing, which
is that if we get the vote out and that is
a very big if there, there's a massive opportunity
to put in play states that are not usually
in play.
All those possibly future purple states are
potentially winnable in 2020 Georgia could
be in play.
Trump won Georgia in 2016 but he trails a
generic Democratic challenger there.
According to a poll from eight weeks ago,
North Carolina, same thing.
Donald Trump won it in 2016 Trump is losing
by five points to win a as yet unnamed generic
future Democratic nominee.
Then you've got Pennsylvania, Wisconsin, and
Michigan, which are always in play for the
Democratic candidate if we actually go and
try to win them.
The polling even in Florida is not super recent,
but Biden was plus three over Trump.
Uh, Bernie was up a similar margin over Trump
the last time that poll was done.
This is not a foregone conclusion.
Trump could also win reelection, but this
is just a matter of do we get the vote out?
So when you hear me talk about this, please
don't react by thinking, oh, we've got everything.
We don't need to work.
We don't need to vote.
We don't need to go and get the vote out.
The reaction should be, wow, Donald Trump
is unpopular in many red states.
If we work incredibly hard, if we mobilize
people who already don't like Trump and agree
with us on policy, but often don't vote.
If we mobilize them to go out and vote, then
we have a shot at some of these states.
And that should be the attitude.
And this polling only supports that view if
we don't get the vote out.
None of this stuff matters.
It becomes completely academic and it becomes
another four years of Donald Trump saying,
the polls said this
before the election and I want again, I don't
want that to happen.
I know most people in the audience don't want
that to happen.
The opportunity is there.
We've got to get the vote out.